[Happy music]
Antiv: My name is Alain Antiv,
From Cameroon, aged 23
I live in a very modest environment,
She grew up in an orphaned father's family in Bamenda.
I have always dreamed
To be a doctor,
But I discovered that innovation in the medical field
Requires at least 30 years of experience.
But I was able to use mobile technology
To innovate and make change
In people's lives at a much faster rate.
Tanako: My name is Konrad Tanko.
As a doctor, I took on a great challenge
It is an attempt to solve a problem
Maternal and child mortality,
And the use of technology
In devising this solution
Even in rural areas
This is one of the most important challenges for me.
Antif: The question that came to our mind,
"Why do we still have maternal and child mortality?
Why is it a big problem? "
After conducting a search,
We noticed that there was a problem with education.
We saw that mobile is a great communication channel
Thanks to its spread,
In collaboration with Dr. Conrad,
We decided to start the GiftedMom project.
Tanko: Project GiftedMom is an application
Contains basic and simplified information
Related to pregnancy, breastfeeding,
And vaccinating children.
The beginning was a real adventure,
But after you finish designing the application and start testing it,
It was very exciting,
Because we saw a wonderful response from those who used the application,
It was exciting for them as well.
So it's technology
Some of them have never seen it before,
Because everything was available on one application,
Everyone loved his acquisition.
Antif: It was of great importance to us
We design a GiftedMom application
So that it is light
It is easy to download.
We also provided content
It can be used even without Internet.
Tanako: The network coverage in Cameroon is very good.
Even in some rural areas
Where there is no electricity,
You can use the Internet.
Antif: We noticed that 70% of smartphone users
In Africa, they use Android.
We wanted to take advantage of that
Bringing the number of users in Africa to 5 million
Over the next three years.
TANKU: In fact, there are more maternal deaths
Children are a global problem.
We are not just targeting Cameroon
We seek to spread this concept in other developing countries.
Antif: There is a desire to spend a lot of resources
Construction of health facilities,
In the long term.
But now we can benefit
Of the spread of smart phones in providing life-saving information.
How glad we were to deploy the GiftedMom application
On the Play Store,
Because it was one of the first products that interested,
It was also interesting that we were sitting in our room
We design things and then publish them
So that the entire world can reach it.
Taco: When we were designing the application, it was some
[Unclear] Medical professionals say,
"Will this bear fruit?
Do you have certainty that
The result will be useful? "
When we achieved the result,
All were surprised and dazzled,
They were very excited,
Then browse the application
They gave us a lot of ideas to develop it more.
That makes me really proud
And enthusiastic as well
To move forward.
Antif: It was inspiring
See the app you created and designed
Serves the intended purpose in
Our rural communities.
Every time a lady is in this rural area
Application
We see the slogan "GiftedMom,"
We are very happy.
We promise ourselves, "We will do better things than that."